hi there just a quickie video here to
say that Sunday my wife and I and
another couple are going to Asia to
initially arrived the evening of the
second of march in Seoul and the
following day we continue on to Yangon
Burma we're going to be in Burma for
eight days then we will be mostly in
north vietnam from the 10th to the 18th
of march and then we will be in seoul
again till the 22nd so is there any
interest in a meetup I don't know if
there's any viewers in Yangon probably
not so many but maybe in Hanoi will be
there from the tent to the 18th of March
and in Seoul we are staying near Tokyo
Tokyo near Seoul station in this
apartment that we've rented for four
days so if there are any ideas of a
meetup in so location somewhere between
Seoul station and the City Hall in that
area please let me know see we can
organize I get together there we go once
again ya Gong Burma or Myanmar from the
3rd to the 9th let's say 10 to the 18th
Liam hanoi and then the basically 19th
20th 21st and then we depart on the
twenty-second of march out of Seoul so
let me know if we can organize meetups
in those locations and thank you for
listening see you later